there are plenty of interesting threads
as it relates to Jo burrows football
future Carson Palmer former number one
overall pick to the Bengals said last
week basically I wouldn't want to play
for the Bengals I tell him not to play
for the Bengals are not committed
winning a Super Bowl meanwhile Carson
Palmer's brother Jordan will be training
Jo burrow awkward and then Burroughs
said later in the week I want to go to a
team that's committed to winning
now TJ Houshmandzadeh former Bengals
receiver added to the team that will be
helping get Jo Bo already he said some
things that even though he trying to
make it look like they're not gonna say
bad things about the Bengals that
there's just this vibe
there's just pieces of a vibe Peter that
could manifest themselves in the first
power play that we've seen since 2004
where the guy who's presumed to be the
top player in the draft makes it known
he doesn't want to play for the team
that holds the first pick
you know Mike my first job in the
covering pro football was in Cincinnati
in 1984 and although I haven't kept
close to the franchise since then what
has happened in that city is obvious to
anybody who looks you know the Bengals
are not a team that is gonna move heaven
and earth to win a Super Bowl that's all
there is to it I wouldn't say it's a
comfortable place but there really isn't
much of a penalty on top of that team
for not winning the Bengals are the most
patient team in the NFL and if that and
Carson Palmer lived it he knows it he
understands it
same people running the team now as when
he worked there so I'd probably trust
what he says they need a new look they
need to revamp I'm telling you I'm gonna
continue to say it changed the uniforms
get the stupid stripes off the helmet
change stuff up they need it
[Music]
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports